[Music]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream the
41st if i am not mistaken is that
correct you are not mistaken i am not
mistaken that's good
that's an excellent way to start
um so let me say a friend of ours
approached me recently and
gently said words to the effect
of even if we manage to save the
republic
if it comes at the cost of your sanity
it wasn't worth it and
i must say on the one hand i understand
this meaning and i appreciate
what is being said to me that somehow
the current event
situation and our political predicament
is driving me a bit crazy on the other
hand i would say my sanity would be a
very small
price to pay to save the republic and in
any case i would like to split the
difference
and recognize that saving the republic
is very important but that
it is um probably incumbent on me to
figure out how
not to go insane in the process
i think that's fair uh one of the things
that we've been doing in service of that
is spending some time on the water
when kayaking we've just begun to try
stand-up paddle boarding and we were
hoping to spend today
not talking about current events um
talking about some
some other things having to do you know
related to
what is going on in the world of course
but not directly
unfortunately some things emerged uh
that we feel that we must
begin begin with so we do hope in one of
the upcoming episodes to devote
most or all of an episode to talking
about schools we've been hearing from a
lot of people
with either children in schools or who
are teachers or staff at schools
and we're not gonna do any of that today
but we are gonna spend some time talking
about what's happening
on the streets what's happening in
oregon and then
also get a little bit to um some some
ways that people might uh be dealing
with
depression and other mental health uh
issues that are
probably coming up for just about
everyone at this point and we're going
to finish with
a follow-on to a question that we got
asked
in last episode about about movies that
we enjoy just to give
people maybe some some things to go to
that have nothing to do with
uh the current moment that will allow
for some
smart um but other entertainment
well i think this is a great plan for
this episode
for future episodes in order to um
depart further from current events
actually i think this is really more of
a partnership with our audience that if
they could do something
to halt the progress of current events
then we would be able to
focus on other matters and phase failing
that
um i think if they just didn't tweet
about it and they could get everybody
else not to if we don't know that
current events are happening
we won't be talking about them so uh
yeah i actually don't get my news
primarily from the tweets but uh it's
gonna have it's gonna take more than
just not tweeting
yeah yeah it is that was a joke not a
great one but
um nonetheless in any case yes we will
be uh
attempting to intersperse as much other
kinds of content as we can
uh in upcoming episodes so anyway you
look forward to that
all right now with that run up to the
current events
yeah so uh many people
will have seen already but we are going
to show a couple of these videos
in which uh people who
are calling themselves black lives
matter protesters
are approaching and uh being
antagonistic
towards restaurant goers so zak if you
want to show
the first video from matt walsh
[ __ ]
and we have another one to show but
before we move on uh for those who were
who are
listening only and not watching you see
one particular young woman
yelling at two restaurant goers and uh
what has happened i think before the
recording started
is uh that the the mob has shown up and
demanded of all of these people most of
whom are eating outside
uh that they raise a fit in a fit
there is a fist in solidarity and uh we
see other people everyone else that we
can see
who's seated at this restaurant has
raised a fist in solidarity
uh i would again refer to those as you
know don't hurt me fists
uh some of them will feel like they're
in solidarity but this is this is the
green grocer this is the don't hurt me
uh salute uh voxlav hovels greengrocer
uh and you also see some of the
protesters mobsters in the foreground at
the end of the video
uh not raising a fist but giving a
finger to
uh the two the couple the the young
straight white couple uh those last two
descriptives which
shouldn't matter at all who are refusing
to do what the mob has demanded of them
so let's show this uh first this tweet
barry weiss
um we found this one through barry weiss
zach
um and then let's if we could show the
video that's embedded in there
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so very much the same kind of scene in
this case it looks like it's just a
woman maybe maybe she's sitting with
someone we don't see them
uh being uh
assaulted by a group of people including
particular
uh a young man a young white man who is
just gets right up in her face
very aggressive uh very you know very
in any other situation i would say that
was clearly a sexed interaction
in which a dude is aggressively going
after
a woman who is sitting there and and not
having any of it she too is not raising
a fist
so barry after um barry weiss after
posting that video
uh which she she got from another source
says also makes me wonder what makes
particular people brave enough to stand
up to a mob
is it a rare personality is it strong
conviction that overrides the fear
and she asks if we might have any
insight
and before we start talking about that
i think this is a good time to bring up
again as i think we did in the last
episode that famous
uh martin niemoller i need to look up
his name to make sure i'm pronouncing it
correctly
a quotation uh from
you know about and after world war
ii in which he says first they came for
the socialists and i did not speak out
because i was not a socialist
then they came for the trade unionists
and i did not speak out because i was
not a trade unionist then they came for
the jews and i did not speak out because
i was not a jew
then they came for me and there was no
one left to speak for me
and i tried to modify that
exquisite and unfortunately doesn't go
out of fashion
uh poem from him last time and i i
didn't really nail it and someone
on youtube who goes by bobby bfat um
did what i think is a better job so
here's his contribution
first they came for the socialists and i
helped them because i am not a socialist
then they came for the trade unionists
and i helped them because i'm not a
trade unionist
then they came for the jews and i helped
them because i am not a jew
then they came from me because they no
longer needed my help
i think that nails it in a way
um yeah yeah it's uh let's put it this
way you could do an exercise
uh on how to rethink and modify this
thing and just simply going through that
exercises
is uh valuable from the point of view of
understanding what the deep meaning is
here because really in some sense
you know is it a poem is it a lesson in
game theory
um is it uh a description of a
historical process you know it's it's
all of these things
um as you know those other things that
you mentioned a description of game
theory
historical um historical process
description of historical process
many certainly those things aren't
required in great poetry but many of the
great poems do exactly that this is what
this is what the power of poetry is this
is what the power of music is
at least music with lyrics that
that they do they sneak in without
pretending not to
important and universal truths without
inherently being pointing to anyone in
particular and so they can
they can allow lessons to come into
people's brains to percolate there
without those people ever having to face
perhaps their own hypocrisy their own
cowardice
their own failure to act in the past
such that they might change the behavior
going forward
so i think they do one other thing which
i think is familiar to you and me from a
teaching environment
they being good poems good poems and i
must say i
you know you mentioned music's music
with lyrics and i really think
poetry is music
devoi devoid of melody that really the
idea is that the form is identical to a
really powerful song
and the idea is that some some lyrics
are so powerful that you don't
actually need melody to float them and
you know
great music great lyrical music has both
characteristics it doesn't require
you could read the lyrics and they would
be meaningful um
but they're augmented by the melody but
anyway so
at another time we should have we should
have more of this conversation it would
be terrific if we had it with your
brother as well
because you and i have almost almost
inverse
responses to what the deepest part of
music are
i think because of in my case because of
the
my sort of origin story with music where
i i played so much classical music
from a young age that it was what i was
immersed in and i never
i didn't even hear music with lyrics
until i was an early teenager such that
um the lyrical part of music seems like
a totally separate thing to me
yeah it is a conversation worth having
and you know i
i do find what happened to you uh
both beautiful and tragic because you
did pick up some a really powerful thing
that i wish i had which is the ability
um to to play an instrument but it cost
you
in in terms of access to all
that is so amazing in in lyrical music
and of course you're
you're arriving there late but um anyway
what i wanted to
say here about the um
the poetry is that the
the thing about poetry is a if you write
poetry you
find that you discover things about the
subject matter that you're writing about
that you didn't know
because you are forced to think in the
neighborhood it basically forces you to
search what
we evolutionists might call the adjacent
possible
because linguistically if the right word
doesn't have the right number of
syllables in it or it doesn't rhyme
then you're forced to think about
synonyms and then you're forced to go
one step
out and then you're forced you know
actually twitter has this aspect to it
also it forces you
to think uh carefully enough to phrase
something well
you know in 280 characters or whatever
it is constraint is almost
always a useful way to find your
creative or analytical outlet
which is why i said in the greg ellis
podcast that i wasn't a fan
of free verse but of course it really
depends on the free verse you can buy
your constraint
somewhere other than meter and rhyme and
then it works just as well but a totally
free verse that expects nothing of the
author
is also not very informative but in any
case the thing about the um
the poem as you called it that you read
it first
you know first they came for the
socialists
um the important thing is that it does
not state
its meaning you infer its meaning by
being led through a series of things
right
you don't even know what the thing is
about until the end the thing is about
at this point we do and so i mean this
is part of the reason for
the value of new versions
of this sort of thing all the time so
that people can continue to be surprised
to find that they've been led somewhere
right and so you know in this case
at the end it's very frightening because
to the extent that
they came from me you know what they
come from me is
right that's death and the fact that
there is no one to stand between you and
it is frightening and the fact that you
don't understand that you lost your
opportunity
to be defended at the point that you
failed to defend it's such an obvious
point at one level and then
we see the game theory fail again and
again and again for you know exactly the
reasons that barry
is asking us if we have insight into
but i wanted to go back to something
about the video yes you said
that they were asked to raise a fist in
solidarity
i am i am inferring that from comments
and such i don't think i don't think i
heard that in the videos
i think it is exactly the inference you
are supposed to take and the thing is it
is simultaneously true
and a lie right solidarity with what it
is true that that is
presumably what they were asked to do
but is that actually
are those words actually reflective of
what the gesture would mean
is is that is that the way in which it's
a lie it's a lie in exactly the same way
that asking people to kneel right we've
seen many
in the early parts of the protests and
riots we saw officials being asked
to kneel with the protesters kneeling is
you know did you kneel you know is this
kneeling as in the game of thrones you
are
showing failty to something is this
kneeling in solidarity it's totally
ambiguous and so the point is
it is a physical mountain bailey where
the gesture has both characteristics
now if i raise a hand a physical
motivation it's a physical mountain bail
if i raise a fist
right like this in solidarity with black
lives matter
have i announced that i believe
that black lives are undervalued and
that we have to do something about it or
have i just embraced black power which
is of course traditionally what that
fist is
now i'm not even against the idea that a
fist
raised for black power is inherently an
offensive thing
i get it but the idea that you're gonna
accost people and force them
to make a gesture that very plausibly
means that they are in favor
of a black power movement right with no
discussion
that this is and i guess i would say we
could we can it's even easier than that
i don't care what it is that a mob shows
up at a restaurant asking me to do
i don't you know if it's if it's a if if
it's demanding that
i show support for a movement that i
myself found it right
why is it that anyone
should feel responsible to or forced to
do that thing no matter how firmly they
are convinced that they are actually
in favor of that thing and so i mean
these really are two separate questions
right
this thing that they're asking you to do
is not what it seems and it's obscuring
a whole lot of other things and actually
you can tell that by the fact of how
they're behaving right here right now
yeah um but also even if you're sure
that the thing that you were being asked
to show support for is something that
you support
you should always be free to show or not
show support for that thing on your own
terms under your own conditions on your
own time
and and so we have these few
restaurant goers resisting even while
everyone around them is sort of looking
a little bit shamed and doing this thing
and how will
how will the people who resisted versus
the guy sitting next to them who didn't
resist
feel how did they feel that night how
did they feel afterwards the people who
resisted
were probably shaken yeah still scared
worried could they be doxxed could they
be found
but they knew that they had resisted the
thing
that demanded of them something that was
not okay
and the guy who avoided the mob for now
how what does he do does he sleep does
he sleep well
i don't think so there's he and there's
off camera and this is we we have to
we have to go yes yes so um
i agree with your formulation and i
think it's exactly right if
if a group of well-intentioned people
confronted us at a cafe surrounded by
people
maybe they came to us and they said you
know so do you support unity 2020
we'd say of course and then they start
uh
you know forcing other people to embrace
it in the cafe suddenly
i'm not even on board with the support
part the point is i don't support it if
it's forced
in any way and
all right so let's get to the i think
it's really in part the issue
that barry is asking us to comment on
which is what happened the people on
camera those who
put up their fists and those who
resisted that's one category and we
because of our evolutionary processing
focus on that because they are the
people in the narrative but this
narrative
is really not even about them right the
person who sees that video which is
who knows hundreds of thousands of times
as many people
as were actually present maybe millions
depending upon how far those videos go
that's the target and i will point out
this is the exact analog
of the evergreen situation right the
protesters flooded in cameras out
right the idea is whatever you do is
about to be broadcast
who do you want to be right now
let's compare these two on the screen
you've got
the people who raised their fist did
what they were told irrespective of what
they actually felt
right they paid one price maybe they
weren't comfortable being told to raise
their fist and they felt weak for doing
so on the other hand there's no focus on
them
right they are unlikely to show up
anywhere
um on the other hand they may walk away
sorry i know you're going somewhere but
they may walk away
actually and some of them may walk away
feeling better about the movement
because they have now shown support and
it will be harder for them to walk away
and some of them and unfortunately i
think it will be a minority
will walk away feeling worse about the
movement now questioning it in a way
that they perhaps had not done before
and wonder if it can do that to people
who
had nothing to with whom they had no
beef
um what else might it do and they might
uh they might actually begin to question
the movement i suspect though that would
be a minority of
those who without thinking about it and
without ever imagining that they would
resist
didn't resist and did raise a fist and
support well i will say again
evergreen teaches us everything we need
to know there was a
faculty colleague of ours somebody who
at one point would have called
a friend who was cornered during
the protests at evergreen and was
frightened by it and wrote about it
and then flipped sides because she was
offered
power in exchange for embracing the
thing which is of course
the underlying dynamic here but oh yeah
all right if we
if we go back to this these cafes
right if you don't raise a fist in that
circumstance then you are
very likely you have reason to expect
that video of you not raising a fist is
going to be broadcast
so whether or not you are doxxed
is in some sense not it because the
the price to be paid for raising a fist
is probably a price between you and who
you were sitting with because they're
you know that's the person you have to
look in the eye after the thing
the person who didn't raise a fist
whatever their reason for not doing so
may have been and it may have been as
good as the one you spell out
maybe the point is hey you're not going
to tell me when i raise a fist and when
i don't i will decide that this is in no
way a statement about your movement
right this is a statement about you not
being able to tell me what i do
right it's a statement about us being
equals right it's a statement
about uh maybe i'm an ally but i'm an
ally by virtue of
the real meaning of that term which is a
pure relationship not a subordinate
relationship
and so in this case solidarity which
sounds like a pure relationship
is actually subordination but in any
case
think about the asymmetry of the game
theory you're one of the anonymous
people who raised their hands
it doesn't get very far maybe nobody
even spots that you were present
okay right you're the person who doesn't
raise your hand
suddenly you're raised you're suddenly
famous for this
right in some sense right you are
not now on the minds of all of the
people who think it's cool to go to
cafes and force people to raise a fist
right you're you're on their feet as one
of the resistors
and you're also broadcast everywhere
else and so
this is the answer to your question
barry is that the game theory plays out
in the mind
in that moment with the what do i do
to reduce the cost of this thing maybe i
don't want to empower
this movement i don't want to become its
iconic resistor
i don't want this to dominate my life
going forward
the point is the bargain is you do
whatever minimizes the chance that the
camera lands on you
but you're answering the inverse
question that she asked well she's
asking what makes particular people
brave enough to stand up to a mob so you
are you are explaining
and this also warrants explanation it
warrants both the question being asked
and it being answered
what explains the vast majority of
people and i've seen numbers in the
range of like 98 99
of people who will um who will raise the
fist
um and you know we have that that is the
answer you are providing right now but
really what we need is to provide people
not just
sort of a litany of you might have these
characteristics in which case you might
be more likely to resist
such demands should a mob come for you
but also
what is it that you can be thinking of
in the moment that will allow you to
have the courage in the moment to resist
all right but this is where this gets so
complicated i agree with you that the
question i answered is the inverse of
the question she asked but it also
i think contains the indicator of the
question of the answer to the question
she did
ask unfortunately this is personal it'd
be much better if
i wasn't the guy in those evergreen
videos
the thing that people need to understand
and i keep saying it and i think people
don't quite get what i'm
saying
why did i do what i did confronted with
students armed with cameras portraying
me as a racist
who wanted me to simply embrace their
movement
publicly so that they would go away and
harass someone else
there was never a choice it never
occurred to me literally did not occur
to me that
that was an option on the table still
doesn't i still
i know formally it's an option on the
table but i do not
register it as one because something
about my
development produced a program in which
that's just not an option on the table
right it's like a keyboard without an
accent on it
right there may be some keystroke you
could use to get there but it's not on
the keyboard
but help everyone else out here like how
how do other people without that
very particular and you know perhaps
unique
in the world uh trait that doesn't even
register
going along as an option even for a
moment how
do the rest of us not only dismiss that
as an option in the moment but really
just
relegate it to the netherworld so i'm
not
ruling it out what i'm saying is
the thing that you're looking for is the
answer
whatever it was that developmentally
produced and it's not it's not just me
it's lots of people but it's rare i've
never heard anyone else describe
exactly what you're saying because you
know there are there are there are many
of us who
will stand up to these things but the
way that you describe this
is so absolute and that kind of
absolute like actually you don't have to
worry
in the moment about what choice you will
make because actually there is no choice
uh is a kind of framing that might be
useful for some people who might
otherwise find themselves unsure
how it is that they should need to act
in the moment
so there is development
and then there are hacks that substitute
for development and
i think the question that people are
really asking and i do get asked this a
fair amount
i think the thing that people they don't
know when i was teaching i always used
to say
to students please answer the question i
should have asked you rather than the
one i did ask you
because very often students will answer
the question you did ask when the right
question is right next door and you'll
discover it a week later and so
i'm going to answer the question that
people should ask which is how do i
bootstrap the developmental
structure to get there because i know my
logical mind knows that that's who i
want to be
how do i override the amygdala in the
moment
and do the right thing right and i would
argue that this is actually
a this is something i i don't know how
they do it in the military but the
military
manages to take people and reschedule
their system of incentives so that they
are capable
of effectively being ordered to engage
in heroism or something like this
and i'm not arguing that that's the
right structure here but my point is
unfortunately there's also a certain
degree of depersonalization
and yeah and such that is not what we
would be i would want to be seen as
advocates that's why
it's why it's not the right answer in
this case but what it is is a proof of
concept
that there is an answer to this question
that can be systematized now i'm not
arguing for a systemic answer and in
fact the poem
that you read about first they came from
the socialists
yeah first they came for the socialists
is
uh a it is a
hack to the extent that you have that
thing resident in your mind
some part of you actually knows that
thing so the question is does that
thing arise in your mind at the point
that they you know come for you
so i mean that is that is one of the
things that poetry is for right
that because because it's in verse it's
easier to call up it's easier to have
remembered in the first place and it
is more likely to come up into your mind
at the point that a mob shows up
right and the other thing is an analog
i've argued
in a couple places i think it did an
early video on um
wisdom and i argued something that then
after i released my video i
it turns out a lot of people have made
an argument similar to this in various
different places but the argument is
that wisdom is either very tightly
related with
or synonymous with delayed gratification
that the idea is we are all as children
uh unable to regulate our desire to have
that
thing and that there are many things
that in order to have the thing you
really want
you have to be able to forego some
superficial substitute for it in the
short term
am i i think i think the marshmallow
test somehow got uh
got revealed as not being what it was
claiming to be
but um but it still looms large for me
as an example of this god it's so noisy
out there today um
so yes whether or not the marshmallow
test is or is not valid like the
stanford prison
experiment may or may not be valid it
resonates
because we all know that there's
something to this and we all watch
children unable to regulate their desire
for that thing and foregoing something
much better and so
the adults we respect are almost always
people who have figured out
how to put off some
instant gratification for a delayed
gratification and the farther you can
delay that gratification
the more powerful this process is and
frankly the thing that's
really hard to grasp is that our
society has caused us
to become very deeply focused on
self as individual and this is
understandable
but as important as self is
self is also part of something right how
important is yourself
if the things that you do to keep
yourself
you know we're watching uh people of
means fleeing
major cities even as they are
politically paralyzed from doing
anything interesting
right they're saving themselves and they
are not taking any risk on behalf
of the larger entity on which we all
depend
that is going to result sooner or later
in that
entity failing and we are actually you
know when you're watching americans
confronting other americans in cafes and
portraying them as uh racist or
otherwise
uh defective for not being willing to
comply with an order
um you're watching the failure of of the
u.s and so the point is
registering the value of that which
is lost if you act in the moment in the
way
that you are being incentivized to act
is the key
can you do no no i i gotta i got to push
back against it's far too analytical
like there's no way that it works at
that level in part because
um you know what you're saying is you're
you're
people are thinking too much about
themselves and not enough about
something bigger and i would argue it's
actually
exactly the opposite that people that
this you know what
what is it that some people have that
allows them to stand up to a mob
well um having this character trait of
being ash negative
which is something that your brother has
talked about and we have talked about
before right
like of of not conforming to
expectations of the people around you
when they are patently
lying right so that's what the the ash
experiment from the
50s revealed and later repeats there's
been
hundreds i think of replications of that
and that was originally just
male undergraduates and it's been done
now in you know across a number of
of people and one of the things we find
for instance is that women are more
likely
to fall prey to the ash confort the
conformity
of of peer pressure basically uh even
when these peers who are new to them
and they will probably never see again
and they are patently telling a
falsehood about what it is they see
before them
women are more likely than men to to
conform
and uh that doesn't mean that all women
can form and no men can form
nor does it mean uh that you can't
change yourself but sort of recognizing
conformity to
peer pressure to social pressure as
something that you are engaging in in
the moment when the mob is there
and saying you know what no who am i you
know who who
am i when i go back and try to sleep
tonight
and report out to my spouse or my god or
my children or my friends whatever it is
will i be proud to look them in the eye
and say this is what i did or will i
look at the ground the way the guy
sitting next to the resistors is with
his fist in the air
knowing that he does not want to look at
the camera but i don't understand
i understand everything you just said
and of course i resonate with it what i
don't understand is where the
disagreement is because i feel like
we're talking about the same thing
i think in the moment it's it's so easy
it's too easy
to be be in that room i mean
so this is this is maybe maybe the
framing
is as you have said many times elsewhere
uh the room is not the room right the
room is in fact the
the internet where this thing is getting
going to get get played out
but in the moment in the room our
understandable
millions of years of human and in
pre-human evolution
cause us to look around and try to fit
to some degree
especially if some are threatening
violence against us
how do you just get out of this
situation right now
you are asking for people to imagine
maybe a bigger
us a a bigger
group that will be better served um by
resistance but that requires staying
in the group think and and
and sort of moving through the emotion
into a purely analytical purely abstract
space
that also doesn't refer back to who you
are at your core identity
and i think you know i think that those
two sort of extremes
of who you are as an individual and who
you are proud to be and who you want to
aspire to be
and how successful are you being
at becoming that best of all possible
use
and how is it that society can
be best for all people that those are
the two
things that that we would we would try
to maximize
and that intermediate social group is
the one that is most likely to get you
to behave
badly and i just i think that
in the moment referring back to yourself
and your individual self and and whether
or not you're going to be able to
live with yourself is going to be much
more likely to succeed
than imagining the the greater
abstraction
okay now i know why we're disagreeing
okay um
let's imagine three states there's self
which is local in space and time to me
there's future self which is local to me
but not in time that is to say how am i
going to feel
an hour after this interaction how am i
going to feel a year after this
interaction
and then there's self but bigger that is
to say i'm part of something that i'm
actually dependent on
and ultimately if that thing fails the
cost to me is absolute
right i think all of i think all these
things are the same
they result in the same alteration of
um of the thought process
in the moment and um i would just
point out and let's take the evergreen
situation because it was simple and
because we know the context of it
right i didn't have a choice i wouldn't
have had a choice if i had been alone
but i was also there in front of my
students right
for me to have a choice in that moment
would have left me
uh completely hypocritical with respect
to everything i had represented to them
as true that doubly made it no choice
you had already publicly defined
yourself
as who you were on the inside and
therefore to to to cave to the mob would
have been a public act of hypocrisy
which won't be true for most people and
so maybe one of the things you're
arguing is
in advance of any such mob coming for
you begin to make public in small ways
who you know yourself to be
so that you have to answer to the self
that you've already established yourself
to be
i believe this is exactly correct and
the reason people don't do it in general
is that they will begin to lose friends
and
yes this goes we are hearing from many
of them
this goes to something you and i have
said on multiple occasions which is that
one thing
that was crystal clear about the
evergreen situation
was that it revealed everybody's
character
now the fact is the people that i might
have thought were our friends
who turned on us i would rather not have
had them as
acquaintances in the run-up to the thing
because what they were
was unreliable and what you need is
friends who are reliable so better to
know
it's better to know as early as possible
and so to the extent
that you see so sad but it's better to
know um
the only thing i find sad about it is
their failure of character
right the fact that though that weakness
is so widespread is sad i don't find it
personally sad i'm
i mourn the narrative that i thought was
true
i i agree and i'm stunned by some of the
things we saw
but i would say the other side of that
is not well you're going to lose friends
it's you're going to discover who you
can trust who you could
find yourself in a foxhole with and be
glad that they were the ones
there and so faculty almost universally
disappointed us they didn't all turn on
us
right many of the people that we were
friends with were
silent which is frustrating or privately
supported or privately supported but
they did not
attack us there were attacks from a
number of different people
but the number of people especially on
the student side who shined
right was more than compensation for all
of the people who
were weak and so i think i think you're
right that the way
the hack that is useful is to explore
this
ahead of time such that the structure
that is there at the point that you are
confronted with that camera
knows why you did what you did
so two other things i think we should
say is one
i don't see any reason to imagine that
the people who didn't raise their fist
had the slightest bit of racism to them
but even if they did the point is
this is not how we interact with each
other
right it is one thing to disagree with
people it is another thing
to weaponize stigma
in order to control them that is
completely unacceptable
it is uh obviously a threat that's being
leveled
in public and we all have an absolute
obligation
to resist uh its being
wielded right no good will come of this
and it certainly will not be good for
black lives
or any any other group of americans
that's right
you said you had two things was that
both no i'm
trying to remember what the second thing
was
it'll come to me in a second all right
well in the meantime let's talk about
ted wheeler shall we oh sure oh good
uh zach would you show the
tweet from ted wheeler that i
sent to you he says the organ cares fund
is now accepting applications
black families and business owners
experiencing housing and security
emergency needs or a loss in revenue due
to covet 19 pandemic are eligible for
cash grants
this is the mayor of portland announcing
the oregon cares fund
uh zach did i send you the link can you
show the oregon cares fund
url that he is linking to
and as it says here on the screen for
those of you just listening
the oregon cares fund is a targeted
investment in the black community from
the cares act coronavirus relief fund
it is for black people black owned
businesses and black community based
organizations so this is
how some of the federal relief from
covet 19
pandemic and lockdowns are being used in
the state of oregon
zach if you would click on facts the
frequently asked questions and scroll
down to how did the organ cares fund
come to exist
uh it's always it's a ways down there it
is
in addition to federal funds directed to
many u.s citizens and businesses in july
the oregon legislature voted to allocate
200 million dollars from the federally
funded cares act coronavirus relief fund
towards specific communities and sectors
of the economy
so the legislature dedicated 62 million
of that 200 million towards quote
specific communities and sectors of the
economy what were the other ones
50 million dollars to cultural
institutions 35 million to emergency
relief checks for those waiting on
unemployment benefits to be paid
30 million to pay workers who need to
quarantine and 25.6 million in grants to
small businesses
none of those other quote-unquote
specific communities and sectors of the
economy
are demographically marked they
are they are potentially specific
sectors of the economy or or groups that
can be identified by for instance
workers who need to quarantine
but none of the others are
demographically or in this particular
case
racially described and
elsewhere on these on these sites you
will find the claim
and i'm just going to start pointing out
when things that are stated as facts are
in fact claims
and not necessarily facts especially
when they come with no references
whatsoever and of course
often the references are lies anyway but
the claims
without even citations are made on these
websites
the organ cares fund website i believe
and on some of the links that they have
to the organizations that are helping
them administer these funds
uh that there are there are two
there are two pandemics that are facing
um us
there's govern 19 and there's uh
systemic racism
and that black people are suffering
worse because of both of them and of
course to the degree that systemic
racism
is a is an ongoing problem black people
are
of course yes one of the groups of
people who are facing that worse but the
idea
that black people are experiencing the
effects of covet 19
at a rate that is i mean really in any
way greater
um than all the rest of people but
to the tune of 62 million dollars
to black people black owned businesses
uh who are experienced black people who
are experiencing housing insecurity
loss in revenue due to cover 19 when
no other demographic gets anything
to that effect is amazing
this is a direct manifestation of
candy's anti-racism we've talked in the
last couple of episodes about
abram max candy and his racism versus
anti-racism formulation which is a
which is a rhetorical trick he is
trapping all of us with this
he is either trapped or successfully
gotten
jack dorsey to put up a don't hurt me
tell me
10 million dollars towards his
initiative at boston university
what's this going to create what is this
kind of quote-unquote anti-racism going
to create
resentment and actual racism
yes i mean it it is a kind of racism but
it's going to also create
the kind of actual racism that that this
whole movement
is pretending to be fighting against
uh it is as i've argued
the ultimate objective is reparations in
every interaction
at every scale every day of every week
every context that's what this is yeah
um the amazing thing about it
is that think about how our system is
supposed to be governed
right our system is supposed to be
governed by a process
in which that which serves the interests
of the public
becomes policy how does that happen
primarily through the election of
representatives
who understand our interests and
manifest them in a policy context
the motivation for this distortion
of the distribution of federal funds
these are federal funds
the motivation for it is the result of
the protests and riots stemming from the
george floyd death i won't even say
killing because frankly i think
uh that that is something we don't yet
know that it was um we can we can
establish that in a court but
at some level um this
is the result of
violence in the streets that are
demanding that are insisting on a
particular narrative
and they are demanding changes and the
policy apparatus
is manifesting those changes without
taking the temperature of the
public this is ted wheeler putting up a
fist in solidarity right this is ted
wheeler putting up a fist in solidarity
and what is fist in solidarity means it
means exactly what we saw in that cafe
yes it means that somebody is solving
their local problem as jack dorsey did
ted wheeler is yeah as governor brown is
so it is the hijack
of governance it is the hijack of the
manifestation
of the apparatus that is supposed to be
serving us all
frankly it's not clear to me that this
is in any way
legal right that you can even distribute
uh funds to people based on race in this
way
i'm sorry on also i would point out that
this is
absolutely 100 percent going to force
the reinvention of the one
drop rule right right lots of people
claim to be black what does black owned
mean right does it mean i mean there's
no workable definition that isn't going
to evolve
involve effectively some claim let the
games begin yeah let the games begin
so so let's just briefly
uh go back over the other four
categories uh
that this 200 million dollars that
the um boy i don't have it on screen
anymore
um 200 million dollars that the oregon
legislature i guess decided to put
towards specific communities and sectors
of the economy cultural institutions
which presumably means things like
museums and zoos and theater
organizations you know live live art
and such emergency relief checks for
those waiting on unemployment benefits
to be paid which
for those not in oregon uh oregon
famously has done a terrible job of
getting unemployment money to people in
a timely fashion
so this is a fix for a failure that's
within the state of oregon itself
and i presume that there are some other
states that are doing really badly but
you know we have friends
on the vancouver side of the border
that's vancouver washington
and friends in portland oregon um both
of whom have been trying to get benefits
in on the washington side it's been easy
and on the oregon side it's not uh
30 million uh it doesn't matter the
amounts cultural institutions
um basically emergency relief checks for
people who are eligible for unemployment
but the state system is failing them so
far
paying workers who need to quarantine
obviously and grants to small businesses
okay all of those i can totally get
behind all of those groups
and then let's see what this um
oregon cares fund does only for black
families and business
owners who are experiencing housing and
security emergency needs or a loss in
revenue
due to covet 19 pandemic okay let's
instead
of making this a racially biased
set of of grants put more money to
grants to small businesses
and put the rest of that money that that
62 million
towards helping with housing and
security and emergency needs for
all oregonians who need it and who apply
and
yes that will mean that some less money
goes to black oregonians but it is
distributed across the board
uh maybe i'm done i know
this makes me so so angry yeah and
god why am i still surprised right this
is this is uh coming from the same
administration that has coddled
these rioters which is now apparently
resulting
predictably enough in businesses fleeing
from downtown i mean what else are they
going to do
businesses who are on the cusp of
failing anyway because of lockdowns
we were just beginning to open up here
in portland which we know better than
the rest of the state
just beginning to open up the protests
begin the riots begin the very next
second
and restaurants are closing retail shops
are closing of course they are
they are and i should point out i
displeases me to even have to say this
but
um evidence emerged in the last week
of protesters hurling
feces
this is incredible right it seems to me
like
at least at the rule of thumb the people
who are
hurling bodily fluids and
feces are wrong right i'd like
somebody to provide a credible example
of where that's not
the case i would say it's quadruply the
case in the midst of a pandemic
yeah right so at some level we've got
anarchists
who existed in portland before the
george floyd protests were regularly
uh engaging in uh protests in the street
uh have taken up with the blm
uh protests and riots and are now
engaging in this vile behavior
and yet that that manifestation
is resulting in large numbers of funds
being
redirected and it's just it's appalling
yeah
okay let's let's pivot can we
please all right um
i want to talk a little bit about some
some of this is new research and some of
it is
not um but the entire
country and i suspect the world is
suffering
a mental health crisis at this point
from a combination of lockdowns that
have gone on forever
it seems and look like there's no end in
sight
in combination now with the protests and
the riots that for many people is
something they only see on screens have
no direct access to
um in combination with in the united
states the presidential election
and you know if you're in california
maybe your house is going to burn down
i mean my god just one thing after
another
so we
for those who are well familiar with our
kind of thinking
our evolutionary thinking it will
probably come as little surprise to you
that we are suspicious
of uh of treatments
for human conditions that look like
quick fixes
and tend to come in the form of pills
not to say that some pharmaceuticals
aren't a very effective treatment for
some conditions some of the time
but we feel and we are not certainly
alone in this
uh that the use of pharmaceuticals to
treat
especially things having to do with
mental health and
mood disorders and anxiety and
depression and such
has been way overplayed so to that
there's a article from 2008.
uh turner at all 2008 called selective
publication of antidepressant trials and
its influence on apparent efficacy
zach you could show did i send that to
you
turner at all 2008 i think i did
um and in it this is a review of
research
registered with the fda on 12
antidepressant agents
like chris are you finding it zach
yeah so
this is a review this is turner at all
2008. it's a review of research
um that was registered with the fda so
not research done by the fda or
inherently funded by the fda but it was
just registered with
federal drug um and the food and drug
administration in the united states
on 12 so-called antidepressant agents
which just means 12
um molecules that are understood
uh to um sometimes work against
depression you know selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors
like prozac being probably one of them
across over 12 000 patients across many
many different research studies it's
review article
they found this group of researchers
that 31
of the research is not published even
though it was registered with the fda
and furthermore the research that wasn't
published
is significantly more likely to show a
negative result
meaning that the drug in question was
not effective in treating depression
than the published research so this is
misleading and could
easily lead to over-prescription of a
reliance on pharmaceutical solutions for
depression
let's just so zach if you want to scroll
to the results i'm going to try to see
if i can see it on my screen here
um oh that's unfortunate
uh here we go uh
so they say
um when we
look according to the published
literature it appeared that 94
of the trials conducted were positive
which means
uh if you look just at the the
scientific literature
uh 94 of trials on these 12
antidepressant
agents appeared to to be effective in
treating
uh depression but when you look at all
of the studies
uh that were registered with the fda
including the ones that weren't
published
actually you find that only 51 of them
are positive so i bring this up
just to suggest once again that
maybe drugs aren't your best you know
pharmaceuticals are not your best friend
for treating
depression and saying well we found
you know there's evidence in the
scientific literature that things are
effective well that does not reveal
the likely bias in um
in publication in fact the conclusions
here are
are careful they say we can't tell from
this
if this is a result the bias results
from a failure to submit manuscripts
from decisions by journal editors and
reviewers not to publish or both so
they're not saying anything about where
the bias may be coming from but just
that there is a clear
bias that the published literature makes
it look
like uh these these drugs to
treat depression are far more effective
than they are so
if if drugs are not the best thing
to be dealing with what is likely to be
a creeping
mental health uh tragedy across many
populations at this point
what might be so we've got two you want
to say something first oh my god
so many things that need to be said in
in response to this okay okay one
that's 2008 right that is long before
this
the so-called replication crisis that's
right okay
two 50 of the papers if you take the
aggregate of the positive and negative
results
were not positive okay
that's after a perverse incentive
because there's a perverse incentive to
do
work that will come out with a positive
and therefore publishable result
so we can't test there's always there's
already selection on these drugs and on
this research
right yeah we have a gargantuan
apparatus with tremendous financial
resources that has an
interest in having results published
that justify releasing these drugs into
the market
it has captured the agency that is
supposed to regulate their safety
even after this fifty percent of this
well so just like the fda is not
implicated here the only
the only thing the fda is doing here is
that the researchers doing
this review paper went and just looked
at the papers that were registered with
the fda
right i got that but what i'm saying i'm
sure they're implicated more broadly
every step of this process is biased
in the same direction yes right yes
every step of the process is biased in
the same direction
and there's still enough evidence to
find that only 50
of the results are positive right now at
the same time
this is you you know so all right it's
very ambiguous that these drugs
are a good thing if only half the
studies say that they work at all
right that leaves out two really
important factors
one is does the fact that a drug has a
positive effect in the short term
mean that it's a good drug it's like the
only thing you track with coping 19 is
deaths
right it's the same thing exactly what
about all of the other lingering effects
that may actually cause a decrease in
quality of life or early death that we
aren't tracking
what about all the side effects of the
drugs what about all the other systems
that they affect
what about all the other drugs you have
to be on to deal with the side effects
of the drugs
right so there is massive downside much
of which will not be measured much of
which is actually
unknowable because if it manifests after
decades it won't have been
captured in these initial studies that
said these drugs
were a good thing you can't say it was
because of that drug right
and then there's the overarching
elephant in the room here
which is we know dick about the brain
okay we really don't know how it works
we know a fair amount about
what it does phenomenologically but in
terms of our
interventions our interventions are all
crude as
hell because a brains are tremendously
different between people
and b because we don't have control at
the level of these systems so
the fact that you're going to dump some
chemical into somebody's system and it's
going to have some alteration that
under the best of circumstances makes
them feel better in the context of this
drug may well make them feel worse when
you remove the drug later
may interfere with all kinds of other
things that make them happy and so
the positive effect of the drug is then
canceled by some other effect in their
life
right null hypothesis should absolutely
be that if you dump a bunch of
neurotransmitter into someone's system
that it's going to have long-term
effects right it's going to have
long-term effects and so
in any case the idea that we take this
as a sophisticated approach that what
we're looking for is the best molecule
to dump on the person's system rather
than looking for a deeper cause
that we do this to children right who
then
end up in this damned if you do damned
if you don't situation later on where
their development has happened
in the context of this drug that then
becomes necessary because
developmentally it was a feature of
their environment
this is so insane as an approach and
anyway i know i know we're headed to
interventions that
aren't pharmaceutical in nature and
that's a really important thing
but it's so much more important than we
give it credit for we we could
we could do two times a week live
streams just talking about
pharmaceuticals
and um why why you should not go there
first when you have a problem and could
should be seeking other forms
of relief for whatever symptoms you're
experiencing i think we could go one
live stream a week just
blowing off steam ranting i think we
already do that
okay all right well good point
all right so we're going to talk about
alternatives to uh what's outside
all right well um i think it's obvious
that now we need to talk about zebrafish
of course i couldn't find a way to talk
about lizards which is usually my
preference but it's going to be
zebrafish are
our longtime listeners know that
zebrafish are the next topic of
discussion as a result of the way we've
built this all i i hope that some people
took bets and made a little money on
that that
you're guessing that zebrafish were
coming up next seriously though um
zebrafish
are a model organism and i think
uh this just that statement needs a
little bit of explaining before
um we will explain why i will explain
why i'm talking about zebrafish here in
a moment
uh can i just say that when you say they
are model organisms you do not mean
like he's a model prisoner you mean
something entirely different i i do
in fact so zach actually if you want to
show my screen just for a moment
this is actually a really a lovely paper
that i just ran across today and i've
only um i've only skimmed it
but for those latent or
nascent biologists who want to know more
about model organisms
actually does um sort of an interesting
job of describing so the the idea
is that uh if we you know and most of
this is in service of
human health and and and medicine you
know
how how many organisms are there out
there
um that we could learn about that would
be relevant something we could learn
about them would be relevant to
something that we could learn about
humans
obviously hundreds of thousands that's
just i pulled that
order of magnitude out of a hat but you
know certainly many many many more than
we could possibly learn everything about
them
and so what has happened in in biology
is that a few organisms have been chosen
as
ones that uh some some people are just
going to learn a tremendous amount about
from the
from the genomics to the behavior to the
anatomy physiology
to the cellular molecular biology the
development you know across the board
i'm sure i'm forgetting whole
whole swaths of biology here but so you
have c elegans
you have arabidopsis you have drosophila
melanogaster
you have um well musc musculus musculus
um and uh and and many more than that
all of which have proven themselves to
be you know we know
enough about that now depending on what
question you might be asking you can
tweak some aspects of what they are
and and have effectively controlled for
a number of things you would have a hard
time doing if you just went out
into nature and picked an organism at
random so let me just say
there's a lot of logic behind this one
of the pieces of logic has to do with
the trade-off
between knowing something in you know
you could imagine
that there are creatures in which some
system would be best studied
and then there's the advantage that
comes from knowing some creature very
well at multiple levels
but one of the downsides of knowing some
creature very well at multiple levels
is that to the extent that that creature
is not representative
you may be misled in terms of
understanding uh
how to extrapolate to the thing we most
typically care about which is humans
and you may become more likely to decide
that outliers are not relevant
because they don't fit a pattern that
you've already begun to see
and frankly once you start throwing out
outliers you start being a
verificationist
you start enforcing the idea that your
model will conform to the model
your future results will conform to the
model that you already had as opposed to
you actually testing a hypothesis
so this this is yet another problem with
model organisms
that said um they have they have their
place and zebrafish is
is one okay so zebrafish is another one
on the list
of uh model organisms that i just gave
and i've got this this paper
um that finds actually
zach you could show i think i gave you
the link for all of ariatal 2020.
uh the title of which is zebrafish show
long-term behavioral impairments
resulting from developmental vitamin d
deficiency
published well to be published actually
in october of this year it's
online now already this is not a
preprint this is just an early online
publication
of of a peer-reviewed primary literature
in the general physiology and behavior
and the the paper
sorry sorry i'm trying to go back and
forth and see um
what it has to say the highlights of
this paper are
uh that when it's when
when juvenile zebrafish are given diets
that are either
replete with or deficient in vitamin d
those zebrafish that were as youngsters
given insufficient vitamin d in their
diets
had more anxiety behavior anxiety-like
behavior as adults
furthermore they swum less
and their startle response was increased
so
again these are just those are the
highlights for the paper and there's a
lot more in there but
juvenile zebrafish that were deficient
in vitamin d
as adults had more anxiety had less
lower activity in the form of swimming
because they're fish and that's what
they do
and and tended to startle more than
those who had
sufficient amounts of vitamin d uh and
so
you know we went through like well what
are why what does it mean for it to be a
model organism
but you also need to know a little bit
about the natural history
actually of zebrafish to know why this
should matter because if zebrafish
are cave dwellers right that never get
exposure to the sun and therefore don't
synthesize vitamin d the way we do
then maybe the idea of taking it out of
their
their diet is ridiculous because you
would never find a zebra fish without
vitamin d
um in the wild because they are not
synthesizing it from the sun anyway
uh well it turns out um zebrafish are
teleos which is ray-finned fish which
are vertebrates
and like us um you know share an
evolution of the brain and the central
nervous system and then
have a majority of shared
neurotransmitters and molecular
mechanisms of physiology
um so that's that's true we can we know
that just from what
where they fit on the phylogenetic tree
but they're also
basically living in shallow streams
shallow clear streams
where presumably there is access to a
lot of
sun so what i take from this and this is
just one
of two things that i want to talk about
briefly here as
you know are you beginning to suffer
from anxiety and depression like
symptoms
rather than running to your doctor for
ssris or similar
um antidepressant agents consider going
out in the sun
and not slathering yourself with
sunscreen from head to toe before you do
so
uh this is yes a result from zebrafish
and yes it's a result and this i think
may help explain further some of what's
going on with
a whole generation of young people whose
parents slathered them with sunscreen
before they were ever allowed to go
outside
but children and adults alike benefit
from having their skin exposed to the
sun and
this is just another result that
suggests that actually
uh it may help with mood as well yeah um
if i read that i only skimmed the paper
but if i read it correctly
also uh increased vitamin d results in
greater job satisfaction among zebrafish
yes absolutely yeah especially zebra
fish who find themselves working in
cubicles
oh man if during their 10-minute breaks
that they're allowed to take each day
they go out into the sun
and leave their cubicles they are they
are much happier
i can imagine they would for one thing
the corners of a cubicle are just not
well suited to the
no they do not have the deep body form
of say reef fish so they don't turn
very well they don't have great agility
they they're kind of built for speed
yeah yeah filter speed you're the first
person to ever say that about zebrafish
but
okay um on a later episode of the
evolutionary lens we will talk about the
deep body form in refish probably we
won't but we could
ah we should okay we should we should
okay finally with regard to depression
and
um what things besides popping pills you
might do
to help yourself out of the funk that is
totally justifiable based on what is
going on in the world
uh there's a 2016 paper that uh
actually there's two papers here um one
two 2016 and one 2019
uh that find that moderate to
intense exercise uh does a tremendously
good job
of impacting depression so let's see
i'll just show
zach i think i did i send you the
belgian at all 2016
uh paper called sweating away depression
the impact of intensive exercise on
depression
so uh what these uh
what this paper finds uh oh again here
we have highlights on the screen
uh that like i said modern intensity and
high intensity exercise was found to
improve
uh depression very low intensity
exercise like walking while it's good
for a whole lot of other things doesn't
didn't seem to be particularly
beneficial
and specifically the participants and
this this is a small study this is 30
men who showed signs of moderate
depression
uh the participants showed a slight
decrease in panic and fear and
increased seeking behavior so that's
this is again not zebrafish but men who
are showing increased seeking behavior
and decreased panic and fear
after spending some regular time in
moderate or intense exercise for
and i think it was i think it was like
an hour a day
three days a week like not not a
tremendous amount even
but not just you know taking a walk
which
has benefits for sure but moderate to
intense exercise with some regularity
yes
[Music]
there's some part of me which just you
know is thinking about the process
uh this is the downside of enlightenment
that we needed hundreds of years of
careful study for scientists to finally
discover that going out in the sun and
exerting yourself makes you feel better
there is another way to discover these
things which might involve just
going outside and exerting yourself and
discovering that you feel better and my
guess is uh
some people may have i think it's been
tried by some of us
um and then let me just point out that
there are many follow-up papers and you
know not even follow-up of course i mean
just like you say this is at one level
so
obvious uh but there's a mcintyre at all
2019
uh article called physical activity and
depression symptoms in women with
chronic illness
and the mediating role of health-related
quality of life which finds very similar
results
uh for not men with moderate depression
but women with chronic illness
that the effects of um moderate
intensity exercise
are are remarkably high right yeah in
treating
um quality of life symptoms and uh and
indeed in some cases the symptoms of
the diseases themselves so um i i was
thinking about this
in the wake of our our kayak
last night so three of us uh brett and i
and our younger son toby went out last
night
and um just on the willamette just for
you know what three miles each direction
we we put in one place and we
um kayak to dinner we yeah we paddled
downstream
um but that it was against such an
amazing headwind
like it was really really really hard we
get out we go to dinner we got back to
the boats actually just as the sun was
setting and so paddled back the 50
minutes or so
um upstream but you know all of that
wind that would have been a tailwind
taking us home had died
so it was it was hard both ways um
and it was really it was it was dark by
the time we got
back there was about a i was calling it
like a six day moon or so that was
beginning to set as we were as we were
pulling into the dock on the far end
and my tweet uh of this live stream
included a very unusual cloud
prism color bow uh that we saw only
briefly a couple minutes and it was gone
just as we were just as we were arriving
towards sunset
no so it was uh as we had arrived at the
dock where we were then walking to get
dinner so it was
an hour before sunset or so hour and a
half before sunset
um but it's all it takes is doing it
to see the change in your own
in your own mood and of course yes your
body as well but
um don't underestimate
the effects of this and don't waste the
summer and the good weather for those of
you who have it now
well while it's here all right i cannot
resist going full evolutionary theorists
on this question so why would you resist
what we have discovered
is that going out in the sun and
exerting yourself
makes you feel better and i'm thinking
what else might so here's the hypothesis
oh wow
what about it's gonna be risky what
about love do you think that might make
people feel
better yeah love actual connection
touch yeah uh finding bags of money
would that
maybe i think that's a shorter term
problem it's shorter term absolutely
you know anything helps okay let's we
we're we're well over
our hour but um we were asked in the q a
last time
about movies that we enjoyed and um
you gave a couple of answers um but i
promise that we'd come back to it and i
thought we might actually just move this
up to the main
um the main live stream just so that
we've
said a couple of movies and i you know
basically i always have a hard time with
this question
and i went to a spreadsheet that we've
made
um that we've shared with our kids
as we're trying to figure out what to
watch and some of them are are
kid appropriate some of them aren't um
but by the way we show our kids
kid inappropriate stuff um i'm not sure
why we do that but we are currently
showing them
game of thrones which has lots of
inappropriate i think when they were
four and six we introduced them to the
life of brian so there's that
yes yeah yeah um so
just a few of the movies from that list
that we've been sort of adding to over
the years that popped out for me
were um movies that we have appreciated
and
only one of these have we gone back to
and watched recently uh
chinatown apocalypse now
the eternal sunshine of the spotless
mind the english patient
lost in translation and the truman show
a very eclectic list and before you
might want to add to it i i will
also say and again none of these movies
have i gone back to and watched recently
although probably i should
that i had an exquisite film education
in high school
um which focused in part on italian and
french new wave cinema
and like i said i haven't gone back to
any of these recently you might mention
jim
yeah so i was brett and i actually met
at crossroads at the school in santa
monica uh where i had been from seventh
grade and um
pratt came in 11th grade having been
invited to leave his former school
which tell that story another time
perhaps um
and it's a it's a private high school
for the arts and sciences built around
an alley
in in santa monica california and jim
hosney
uh was he's retired now but was an
utterly extraordinary teacher there and
i had him for
five as a teacher for five i think of my
six years that
um i was there and um and
some of the films specifically in the
sort of italian and french new wave
cinema
uh genre that he showed us and had us
analyze
as 9th 10th 11th 12th graders
were that i that i enjoyed at the time
were fellini's satirican
from 1969 true foes jules and jim
from 62. boone wells the discrete charm
of the bourgeoisie from 1972
antonioni's blow up from 1966
and bertolucci i think berlucci only
wrote the screenplay for this
um didn't uh direct it but berlucci's
1900
which came out in 1976. so that's
um again a fairly diverse list of films
all of which
uh i recommend do you have anything to
add
yeah you uh you hit several of the ones
i had highlighted from our list
chinatown is marvelous from the point of
view of understanding
how things actually function great
many people believe the greatest
screenplay ever written eternal sunshine
of the spotless mind is
great for embracing the messiness
of being human in light of
the technological desire to interfere
with it
um lost in translation uh i would say
a similar topic i would add that's one
that we did actually recently watch
um again yeah it struck us both as
as remarkable yeah it's a great great
film um
i would add rushmore especially if you
have someone in your life
um who's smart but doesn't uh
fit very well with school it's kind of
an important
um important film for that reason
um yeah what else was i thinking
maybe maybe that's good enough for now
um but anyway those those are great
films and
we'd be interested in hearing oh i would
say we watched 12 monkeys
right before covid showed up on our
radar and that is an interesting film to
look at
now it was just pure happenstance
literally i think we had not heard of
kovid
yet and we watched 12 monkeys but
it's quite something brazil
i also find has aged quite well as a
film
maybe that's it maybe that's it so we
will
how's this become our habit take a
15-minute break or so
and um come back afterwards
to answer your questions from this
hour's
super chat as many as possible and then
your questions from the super chat next
hour
uh one announcement i should say
um there's been a slight change in
schedule
at unity2020. um our
voting system is apparently ready but it
is not sufficiently well
tested that we are ready uh to release
it so we are going to get there as
quickly as possible
but we did not want anything to
potentially
upend a good uh honest accounting
so anyway stay tuned and we will give
you information as soon as voting
is possible uh excellent and
uh as as usual um
i want let's see what did i want to say
ah there you can
become a dark horse member at my patreon
not
this sunday we will have our monthly
private q a
at 11 a.m pacific for those people who
have joined
at the 5 level or above
and there is a discord server that is
available as a benefit
at uh at both of our patreons
yep and um we are coming towards the end
of august
believe it or not so that means that the
next
two patreon discussions on my patreon
are
going to be happening soon so you might
sign up there
maybe that's it and we'll see you in 15
minutes that's right be well